Hi Veronica.
Hi Steve.
Today, I'm gonna talk with  Veronika Mark
of Moscow about just how much can you
learn on your own in a place where the
language you're learning is not spoken.
Now, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you're following me on a
podcast, please leave a review.
I appreciate it.
So hello, Veronika.
Hi.
We are going to speak in English
because Veronika's English is amazing.
Absolutely amazing.
Veronika has a website, a YouTube
channel called English with Veronika
or with Veronika Mark, which is it now?
With Veronika?
With Veronika Mark, yeah you were right.
With Veronika Mark, okay.
And we just had a conversation
in English, and her English is,
I would say flawless, flawless.
Now, would I say I would mistake
her for a native speaker?
Not quite, but almost.
And the use of words, the way you put
words together is completely native
speaker, uh, intonation, everything.
There's just very few little
things that give you away.
But what I find very interesting
with Veronika is you have basically
lived your whole life in Moscow.
Yeah in russia.
Yeah.
I I'm not from Moscow.
So I lived, yeah.
I lived in a different city until I
was, uh, 17 and then I moved to Moscow.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we often hear people say, you
know, to learn the language really
well, you have to move to the
country where the language is spoken.
And so, and you are living
proof that that's not necessary.
So how did you go about achieving
such a high level of English
without really leaving Russia?
Yeah.
So thank you for your question.
Uh, when I was in school, like in
Russia, it's mandatory for every
student, for every kid to start
learning English at school as a,
as the first foreign language.
And, uh, obviously when I was a kid, like
I was eight years old, I didn't really
care about foreign languages at all.
And for me it was just another
subject that I didn't like.
And I feel like the moment that I realized
that I actually really enjoy English was
when I was, it was my, uh, yeah, I think
I was in high school, my junior year in
high school, and I was just so excited
to learn, to start learning English.
And first of all, I only
focused on the input
I was just listening to
something, reading books, just...
first, I started with some stupid
books for kids, because for me it
was really entertaining and they
were actually really interesting.
And, uh, I had a, I had an
English teacher, she was Russian.
So, but she had a very good level
of English and she helped me a lot.
She was always motivating me
and she, she was just amazing
and I'm really grateful for her.
And, uh, then there was time when
I had to prepare to go to college.
I had to take some tests and exams,
and I decided to take English as my
exam because in Russia we can choose.
Um, so, and then the, that is when
I really had to prepare well, and,
but obviously when you prepare for
a test, it's a little bit different
than what you actually need, like
to communicate with people or to
just read something in English.
And when I moved to Moscow,
this is when I realized that
I really lacked just, yeah...
I had a lot of things that I didn't know,
like culture wise and just vocabulary,
my vocabulary wasn't really as great.
And, uh, one of my professors, English
professors told me that I should really
look into accents and think about because
my English was already pretty good.
And there was one thing that
she said could be better,
which is my pronunciation.
Uh, because sometimes I mixed up
accents, I would say something in
a British accent and then another
word would be an American accent.
Then my Russian accent
obviously would be also there.
And this is when I was like, okay,
now I need to really think about
improving my accent and I try to
focus more on the American accent.
And this is when I learned all
those rules of connected speech.
Um, yeah, all of those different
sounds in the American English.
And obviously still every single
day I focused on the input because
I just read a lot in English.
I love reading in any language, really.
So for me, it was just natural.
It's just the reading in English.
And I really love listening to podcasts.
So I should probably add to that.
So you speak English, you speak Chinese.
What other languages do you speak?
French at a beginner level, yeah.
At a beginner level.
And your Chinese is...
How would you classify it?
Intermediate, sometimes when I
practice more upper intermediate.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so basically when you were very
young, you weren't that interested.
And then at the age of 16, you become,
you, you became very interested?
Yeah, very interested.
And, uh, it's interesting.
A lot of parents, they want their kids to
learn languages, English in many cases.
And so they sort of, they want to expose
their kids to as much English as possible
when they're three years old or something,
they really pushed this early immersion.
And my experience has been that if
the kid is interested, that's fine.
But if the kid isn't interest, don't
push because it's never too late.
If somebody gets motivated at age 16,
they will, they will go and learn.
And at the other end of the spectrum, you
have countries like Sweden, where all of
the television programs are in English.
Uh, I shouldn't say they're
all in English, but they're
in the original version.
So if it's an American television
program or a British television
program, all the kids are going to
watch that in the original version.
So Swedish kids, without even trying,
they show up at school, they already have
a fair level in English just through all
of that input, but you would not have
had that because in Russia you would not
have heard so much English on television.
Definitely not.
No.
So you would have to make a special effort
to get that input, uh, through whatever
you can find on the internet and so forth.
Yeah.
So the podcasts that you
listen to is that mostly for
pronunciation, is it for vocabulary?
Uh, how much opportunity did
you have to use the language?
Um, I think right now and when I was like
16 or 18, I primarily focused more...
okay.
When I was like 16, 18, I focus more on
the podcasts that actually taught English.
They were, yeah, the hosts
were native speakers of, for
example, like American English.
And they would explain some
expressions in English.
They would talk about the culture
and it was really interesting
to me, but right now I never
listened to these podcasts anymore.
I just listened to podcasts
for native speakers news.
I love listening to the news
sometimes and just some interesting
podcasts about anything, really,
anything I'm interested in.
Is it easier to find, I presume it's
easier to find the content of interest
in English than in Chinese, for example,
or maybe there's lots of Chinese.
I'm not learning Chinese right now I
don't know, maybe there's lots of stuff.
It's easier, I would say it's easier
and faster to, to, uh, find some new
content in English than in Chinese.
But if you know where to look, then it's
no problem finding anything in Chinese.
So if a person wants to achieve a high
level, without having the opportunity to
travel to where the language is spoken,
even though that might be a long-term goal
to go to the country where the language
is spoken, that there is a lot that
they can do on their own, and that it's
possible to achieve a very high level.
And what do you think are the,
the main ingredients in, in order
to be successful in order to
achieve a high level in language?
Uh, without having the opportunity to
be in the country, what, what, what
would you say if you had to name, say
three things that are essential in order
to be successful, what would they be?
Um, being consistent is definitely
going to be one of them.
And I think it applies to everything we
do in life, not just learning a language.
Yeah.
If you want to be good at sports,
you need to be consistent too.
Uh, so yeah, it would be consistency,
focusing on the input and I think the
third one is also going to be about
something about not stressing too much,
not worrying too much because the thoughts
we have in our head sometimes for example,
uh, it didn't help me at all when I was
younger to think that my English was not
good, that I couldn't communicate with
people because I would always feel scared
and not ready to talk to other people.
So yeah, definitely the thoughts
we have, our mental state
is really, really important.
Well, you know, I
completely agree with you.
Uh, we've got to give ourselves
credit for what we achieve and not
criticize ourselves because we can
always improve, but we all, we will
also continue making mistakes and
having things we don't understand.
And none of that matters if we want it
to be a hundred percent comfortable,
we stay in our native language.
Yeah.
Anytime we're speaking in
another language, it's, it's less
comfortable, but it's more fun.
Yeah.
And I think you're a proof that
great things can be achieved, even if
you're not surrounded by the language.
So thank you.
I hope that your example
can, uh, encourage people.
And, uh, if we have, uh, as I do have
viewers who are not native speakers
of English, uh, they may want to
check out your YouTube channel,
uh, English with Veronika Mark.
And I'm sure they'll find many useful
tips as well as lots of encouragement.
So, thank you very much and good luck
in your language learning journeys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Bye.